the imf is not happy that el salvador
has a bunch of bitcoin on their balance
sheet nor are they happy that el
salvador has made bitcoin legal tender
now the imf the international monetary
fund they are urging el salvador to go
ahead and get rid of bitcoin as legal
tender now this is literally the
equivalent of a competitor saying hey
you're being disruptive please stop
doing that or somebody's saying oh my
god that competitor is disrupting us
shut it off shut it off of course people
around the world realize the second that
the imf starts saying something and
trying to get el salvador to roll back
this innovative strategy
then that must mean that they are
worried so of course as i said this will
be very very interesting to watch as
this unfolds the imf technically doesn't
actually have any say over el salvador
they simply are an organization that can
provide emergency funding and loans and
they end up working with about 190
countries around the world but
ultimately the imf is not actually in
charge of el salvador they can't make
them do anything and so if you go and
you actually read right off the
wikipedia page of the imf their job
their mission is to foster global
monetary cooperation secure financial
stability facilitate international trade
promote high employment and sustainable
economic growth and reduce poverty
around the world this organization was
formed in 1944 and imf ain't done none
of that [ __ ]
bitcoin has done more of that than the
imf bitcoin has coordinated and fostered
global monetary cooperation it has
secured financial stability for millions
of people around the world it has
facilitated billions of dollars of
international trade on a daily basis it
promotes high employment literally one
of the fastest growing job sectors in
the world is the bitcoin cryptocurrency
industry and it has sustainable economic
growth it's just up and to the right up
only baby and it also continues to
reduce poverty around the world because
it attacks the number one cause of
poverty which is the debasement of the
currency in the united states 45 of
americans hold no investable assets and
as we continue to devalue the dollar
those people get poorer and poorer and
poorer they can't catch up they're stuck
in the rat race so ultimately the first
principal solution to that problem is to
fix the money if you fix the money you
fix the world bitcoin is doing a better
job than the imf at the mission of the
imf on top of that the imf as of 2020
has about 667 billion dollars in their
funds bitcoin is bigger than the imf
bitcoin has done a better job than the
imf and el salvador has chosen to
embrace bitcoin to plug their country
into the decentralized digital network
why is it that all of a sudden when
there is a free market asset an asset
that anyone in the world can use without
permission from anybody else
decentralized hierarchical
legacy incumbent organizations they get
fearful they get scared and they start
trying to advocate for countries like el
salvador not to continue down this path
my friends whenever you smell fear like
this it usually tells you somebody's on
the right track
so i don't know what's going to happen
i don't know how this plays out but what
i do know is that more than four million
salvadorian citizens now have bitcoin
and it has re-energized a country that
is a dollarized nation
it has given them some sense of
sovereignty
and now there are people around the
world that are going there from a
tourism standpoint and they continue to
seek out el salvador as a place of hope
of potential freedom of economic
prosperity and ultimately what they want
to see there is what exactly is going to
end up happening now that they've
plugged their country into bitcoin
we've got this quote from the imf press
release that says they stress that there
are large risks associated with the use
of bitcoin on financial stability
financial integrity and consumer
protection as well as the associated
fiscal contingent liabilities they urged
the authorities to narrow the scope of
the bitcoin law by removing bitcoin's
legal tender status
some directors also expressed concern
over the risks associated with issuing
bitcoin-backed bonds
ultimately it doesn't matter
the president of el salvador doesn't
care either he's going after all of
these issues he's saying actually i
think financial stability financial
integrity consumer protection and fiscal
contingent liabilities they're worse off
in the old system we're going towards
the future we're going towards this new
technology we are going to embrace this
new thing called bitcoin he tweeted
right at the imf and he said i see you
imf that's very nice this is a gif he's
just shooing them away we'll see whether
that ends up being a smart decision or
not what do you guys think when you see
the imf saying that they're urging which
by the way means they can't do anything
they're urging el salvador to get rid of
what i was gonna say is like that's
that's a pretty empty threat there like
hey you should do this and i i think
it's wrong to completely just disregard
the imf because they're like the meme of
the old guy yelling at bitcoin like i i
get it uh but ultimately there are some
risks associated with it right it's it's
obviously been very volatile over the
last few months uh they're allowing um
you know their citizens to go pay and
bitcoin at certain merchants maybe some
that do not want to accept it and some
that do but ultimately you have to be
aware of the risk but i think the the
the overarching theme here is like
for it to become a currency right we've
moved in the realm now where i think
everyone believes that it's a store of
value uh it's much better in a digital
aspect than gold and physical gold with
everything that is associated with that
right not only from a supply and demand
perspective but also the cost associated
with storage and all these other things
so we moved into that realm but for it
to really become a currency and become
less volatile on all these different
things like these are the steps that
have to happen right so uh in my in my
mind like good for el salvador for
standing up to them and saying hey our
citizens are going through all of these
different problems right we think
bitcoin is a good solution to most of
these problems or at least some of these
problems so we're going to fight you
guys and we're going to continue to do
this we're going to acquire bitcoin he
literally bought 410 bitcoin the other
day uh right and then this happened
right after that so they now own 1500
bitcoin or somewhere around there and
ultimately what we're seeing is like
they just don't care right he's giving
their citizens an opportunity uh to see
how this plays out and what we've seen
is like i ultimately there's going to be
some people that like it and some people
that don't like it right just given kind
of the political structure within their
country some people are going to hate
kelly for whatever he does and some
people will love him
but at the end of the day
more people have downloaded the chief of
wallet than have traditional bank
accounts they have more access right the
unbanked and underbanked people are
significantly better off with digital
currency than they are with physical
cash and uh and at the end of the day
and ultimately what we're seeing is that
they are adopting this at a large scale
so whether you want to
say it is volatile and they shouldn't do
it or not the citizens are obviously
believing something completely different
about it and they are attempting to
adopt this as not only legal tender but
but one of their stronger uh more used
currencies i think good for them john
what do you think
the imf has no real power here right um
el salvador has been trying to get a um
bond from the iron um basically loan
from the uh imf for since early 2021 so
they have no real say here i think
bitcoin does all the things that they
are trying to solve right that financial
stability financial integrity consumer
protection all the things that uh
bitcoin does i think the imf is just
looking at it from a different view uh
but kelly he's becoming the ultimate
troll in my mind right anyone that says
anything to him he's now
taking the stance of don't really care
what you guys are saying don't believe
what you guys are saying i already have
conviction in this asset i think this is
a long-term play for him um he's doing
bitcoin city like so he's trying to
bring attention to his city he's doing a
very very good job of that um but i
think he just needs to be a little bit
more weary of like
who's he chewing away who's he's not you
have to keep an open mind what people
are saying because new information is
developed every day in this space um but
regardless of that he's he's changing
the world i i think when it comes to
some of that stuff like you obviously
have to uh treat some people with kind
of a different level of respect than you
would others just given your
circumstances as the leader of a country
and kind of how people perceive you but
ultimately and this goes back to our
discussion from the other day like this
[ __ ] is hard right there is no marketing
team for for bitcoin it's not a company
they do not have a marketing department
they do not spend billions and billions
of dollars annually to market the
product and network and services of
bitcoin to everyone else right and get
adoption and do all these different
things if that was the case then maybe
what he would be doing is absurd but
it's really difficult to get people on
board with this stuff and i think uh
bitcoiners and people that are involved
in the network from every capacity
miners everyone else
need as many people as possible
preaching the benefits of this stuff to
as many other people as they can so i
think ultimately what we're what we're
seeing and what we are going to continue
to see is people step out of that box
and say hey look i'm going to take on a
little reputational risk here and that's
exactly what he's doing he's take on
reputational risk and whether he cares
or not is a different story but
ultimately that's what he's doing he's
taking on reputational risks to push
forward an asset that he believes can
change the lives of some of the citizens
in his country i tend to think that he's
on the right side of history we're going
to find out but uh it's fascinating to
watch uh the old incumbent organizations
and how they think about their role and
their ability to provide influence
versus actual control and what to exert
and when to exert it
game on